kontakt im konzert oder in der
gaststätte haben wir uns dafür
entschieden wirtschaftskreislauf so weit
wie möglich restaurants sind ja auch
teil des wirtschaftskreislaufs
wirtschaftskreislauf so weit wie möglich
und kita und schulen und natürlich
krankenhäuser pflegeeinrichtungen und
die infrastruktur so diese entscheidung
ist eine politische wenn ich mir sonst
auf malle wo sind überall kontaktpunkte
in der gesellschaft kann ich auch andere
bereiche herausgreifen
aber ob wir dann wirtschaftlich so
durchkommen dass wir allen auch noch
helfen können und auch dass die
richtigen gesellschaftlichen prioritäten
sind das muss man diskutieren nur wer
sagt jetzt habt ihr an der falschen
stelle geschlossen
der muss mir genau sagen an welcher
stelle wir es dann sonst machen soll
und jetzt sind wir es den privaten
bereich gegangen indem wo es an die
verantwortung die die messen sind in
deutschland nehmen wir machen wir nicht
so auch radikale maßnahmen gesehen
unseren nachbarländern zum teil im
augenblick wieder in kraft sind
und das bedeutet aber wir müssen ein
stück an die vernunft und an das
verständnis appellieren lehrer die jetzt
unter arbeits einschränkungen leben
müssen oder gar nicht arbeiten können
und die entschädigung bekommen und dann
auch in der hoffnung dass viele mit uns
teilen dass das aufrechterhalten von
schulen und kitas und des
wirtschaftskreislaufs jetzt das
wichtigste ist und der verwandtenbesuch
die urlaubsreise der restaurant besucht
die feier im kleinen kreis zu hause und
das auftreten in großen gruppen draußen
vielleicht wenn ich die reduzieren muss
das verträglichere ist aber schwer
bleibt kein mensch hat sich sogar
gewünscht
wir können ja nicht zusehen wie wir dann
sozusagen menschenleben
optionen die wir die überlastung unseres
gesundheitssystems machen denn diese
situation möchte ich nicht kommen das
möchte ich auch pflegerinnen und
pflegern und ärzten und betroffenen
nicht zu mehr nachrichten und breaking
news nur bei bate schau dich hier das
nächste video an und vergiss nicht zu
abonnieren